hi there today we're going to look at
auditing radicalization pathways on
YouTube by Manuel Horta romário and Al
so this paper is a bit different than
the one we're usually looking at but
since I'm a youtuber and this is in the
kind of a data science realm I thought
it fits neatly so um yeah we'll have a
look and this is mostly going to be an
analysis and my opinion on it so you
know take that for what it is this is in
my opinion a paper where you can see
very well what what it looks like when
you deceive yourself so when you have a
hypothesis of something and then only
collect data that matches that and you
don't think like you don't think of
simpler solutions for that explain the
data and therefore you don't think of
experiments that could differentiate the
simple solutions from what you propose
so it's a good example of how you can
kind of trick yourself into believing
you found something and this isn't this
isn't now about YouTube or anything this
happened to me so many times always pays
off to take a step back and say is there
a simpler explanation for what's
happening and this is what I think is
exactly happening here so I'll present
to you their hypothesis and then I'll
present to you my kind of what I think
is going on and a model that explains
the data much much much easier and
simpler and actually better so let's
let's dive in the this paper basically
claims the following so on YouTube there
are channels and channels or you know
independent channels they make videos
and you can actually arrange these
channels so each dot here is a channel
you can arrange these channel
in kind of a network and Tube channels
you can claim they're connected and it
can be a connection strength or whatever
for simplicity they can be connected if
for example their topics are similar if
they reference each other if they are
recommended by YouTube from each other
if they have the same users watching
those same channels or the videos of
these channels there are a number of
metrics where it could you could you
could make channels connected but all of
them will turn out similar like we'll
give you the similar structure of
channels being connected
oh that's connected twice um so so so
you can kind of build a graph of how
these channels are connected and what
you can do then is you can you can
cluster them you don't have to build a
graph to cluster them but you you can
cluster the channels and what will
emerge are parts of the graph that are
very well connected right here this
might be connected with this and with
this parts graph that are very well
connected and they're kind of within
well connected within and more sparsely
connected to two others like also have a
larger distance in between them so if
you start out from one channel and
you're kind of watching recommend videos
and recommend channels and so on you you
stroll along here you will get much
faster to these things than to the other
things so these these are called the
communities usually in these kind of
Network social network analysis so on
YouTube you know there's a community for
makeup there's a community for sports
within sports there is a community for
soccer there's one for basketball and so
on so these are all these kind of
communities that you can discover by
clustering this paper mainly deals with
three communities namely the first of
all is the the IDW and which is the
intellectual dark web they discuss this
here so the intellectual dark web is
they describe
a group of individuals that are in a
rolling conversation with each other
about topics that are let's say usually
kind of difficult to to talk about such
as gender differences or intelligence
research in certain areas or even you
know regular politics but kind of the
the intellectual darkweb are a wide
variety of people that basically are are
conversing with each other about topics
it's that the description is a bit vague
but the the main aspect is conversation
and maybe topics that are kind of on the
on the edge of what's acceptable to talk
about but the opinions range widely on
these topics the second group is the alt
right and the alt right here is kind of
the the they're defined as ethno
nationalists for example here is an
example the fringe ideas such as a white
ethno state white supremacist ideology
and so on so specifically ethno
nationalists nationalists that i think
nations should be organized to along the
lines of ethnicity and the the goal of
the paper is actually to to show that
there is a kind of a dangerous pipeline
on YouTube that will drive people to the
alt-right and drive people into these
radical ideas of the outright kind of
in-between is the alt light which is
here defined as civic nationalists which
is simply as I understand it means that
people should be organized into nations
not along ethnicity but just should
organize themselves into sovereign
communities and it would be more of your
libertarian classically liberal people
whereas the ultra would be more of your
let's say authoritarian right right-wing
person so these three communities they
have a fourth community which is a they
call a control group and the control
group consists of what they say are kind
of math mainstream channels on YouTube
simply to differentiate them from these
three and to see what's going on with
them and if there is a difference so
this is this is kind of the de set up
and as I said the hypothesis is the
following people go on YouTube so
YouTube is here YouTube people come on
YouTube they go around right they they
explore a bit and all of a sudden they
find IDW videos these are recommended by
YouTube on a fairly regular basis right
now they're interesting people find it
they find it interesting answer and then
they're from the IDW there are
recommendations and links to the alt
light and the out light are still so as
I read this paper there is kind of a an
undertone kind of the IDW in the out
light are still okay like they there
they discuss ideas that are you know
sometimes political and so on but the
real the worry is that all to write the
kind of radical right-wing ethnic
nationalists and i mean yes it did the
formulation I can I can agree with
and then they claim so you find the IDW
that they have links to the alt light or
links I mean recommendations and so on
and from the alt light and to a certain
degree also from the IDW you can then
find the alt right so even though user
that goes on YouTube at first isn't
likely to find the alt right videos
because its fringe its extreme and so on
by through the YouTube recommendation
algorithm basically by going to the IDW
finding this then from there they'll
find the light and from there and from
the IDW they will then find the
right so they claim that there is this
pathway of radicalization here that kind
of pushes people towards the alt right
and that's their their hypothesis and
they claim that they have evidence to
support this and I claim that there is a
simple solution namely the first of all
let me state I don't like the alt right
I think their ideas are despicable
I should go without saying though I have
said it now so you know just as a
disclaimer I'm not defending anyone here
I'm simply saying this paper has a
simpler explanation for their data
namely what I think is happening here is
YouTube again is channels each dot here
is a channel channels can be clustered
as such right there as we saw before I'm
just drawing more of them right now but
all channels janus janus janus channels
channels so what I think is happening is
there is a control group what they call
the control group it's over here it's
large control alright it's a bunch of
channels then which is kind of
mainstream media then over here there is
let's say alternative media where all of
these three groups belonging to me so at
some point you will have the IDW then
maybe a bit further away from the
control group but very close to the IDW
would have the alt light and very close
to the - maybe here you would have the
alt-right right but so notably the in my
model the IDW in the alt light are kind
of close together they are in terms of
comparative distance
so if you close through these channels
but let's say all the answer topics or
and so on it will it will turn out that
all of these three are far far away from
the control group those two are very
close to each other and then they're
here there is some distance but how much
you know how much distance it is a
question but of course it's going to be
smaller distance than the distance to
the control group here I mean I could I
could draw the alt-right
maybe a more accurate picture would be
something like this
all right here so whatever I mean it
doesn't it doesn't matter that the
details but the distance here is smaller
than the distance to the control group
right and in in this model a second
thing is also important namely the
alt-right as you can see here is much
much smaller than the IDW and the alt
light and these again are much smaller
than the control group and this I think
accounts for most
so the distance relations between these
and the the size of the chan of the
clusters account for most so that with
size I mean mainly channel number of
channels and also audience this accounts
for most or most of the data better than
their model so just keep this in mind
right and my model of course doesn't
include any kind of pipeline that they
suggest so first of all they go ahead
and they say all right we they collect
channels so they collect data for this
and you know we could go over how they
collect the data and criticize that and
so on very human annotation and they
start from already published reports and
so on which themselves can be criticized
I don't I'm not going to go into their
data collection methodology it can have
mistakes but
any collection methodology can have
mistakes what they end up with is a
number of channels and here are the top
channels from each category and you can
as you can see all right all right
intellectual dark web and control so
already here you can see pretty clearly
the model I have in mind namely and they
acknowledge all of this by the way look
at the size of the alt-right channels
the biggest ones compared to the size of
the alt light and the intellectual dark
web there's much much smaller in number
of views and then compare this to the
size of the control group the control
group again is again the larger than the
other two groups so just keep it in my
second thing to keep in mind
look at these channels maybe you know
some of them Joe Rogan sargon of akkad
of these Paul Joseph Watson sticks hacks
and hammer
these are youtubers like these are
individuals making YouTube clips
creating content for YouTube being on
this platform whereas if you compare it
with the control group what's here Vox
GQ Wired Business Insider these aren't
youtubers these are these are websites
or traditional media companies or
they're their own kind of blogs and so
on that have a YouTube channel where
YouTube is one of the outlets of this
media company so I think there's a
there's a giant discrepancy here in the
control group that can explain also some
of this data that you see so keep that
in mind
I think the control group they say they
don't try to capture the user dynamic
with the control group but I think that
there's many problems with this control
group including the fact that these are
these are kind of traditional mainstream
media that just have YouTube as an
outlet and moreover a lot of these like
Fox or vice they are clickbait media and
rage bait media that it has worked for a
number of years but it's the algorithms
are becoming more attuned to kind of
click bait and these are crashing fast
whereas the kind of more youtuber people
they are they're not susceptible to that
much to kind of the the abolishment of
click bait all right so these are this
is the data they have all these channels
they have all these videos and they
first of all give some some some stats
all right here you see on the bottom is
always the year so they do this over
time and you see the active channels
which are channels that have uploaded
videos in some time see the control
group again is larger but has started to
flatten out in the last few years
whereas the these communities they are
relatively flourishing another
interesting point is that the paper
somehow tries to tie this to the
election of Donald Trump in 2016 but I
again I think this is just kind of in
there to to gain relevance a lot of
these kind of trends and so on you'll
see already start before that so in so
that the start of the rise here if you
see these these bumps here and so on a
lot of them start before 2016 so as we
go through this make up your own mind of
how much this is actually tied to the to
the election or not I think it's much
more the years when kind of clickbait
started to go down as a as a business
model
never mind though so the active channels
growing though the control group not
growing
as much videos published even though the
control group isn't growing so much they
still publish the the most videos but
you can see generally the site is
growing generally YouTube is growing
like counts and here you see something
interesting starting to have namely
these communities especially the alt
light and the intellectual dark web
they're starting to catch up and this is
one of the things that the paper also
states is that if you look at for
example comments per video this the
light and the intellectual dark web
outperform the control group vastly
right also if you look at views per
video and likes per video the the
control group simply don't have an
engaged audience which I think first of
all is because they produce clickbait
second of all they're just not that
interesting and third of all there are
not youtubers like this isn't their
thing they're just simply an outlet but
yeah so that's that's kind of a one just
kind of a bunch of metrics that the that
they show here the next table is a bit
more interesting in the next table they
do user intersections so what they do is
they collect all these videos and then
they collect all the comments of these
videos and the comment of course always
comes with the username you need to be
logged in to YouTube to make a comment
and they see which users comment on
multiple videos or videos of multiple
categories and then they can look at aha
okay a user how many users of category a
also comment and category B and vice
versa so they have two metrics here
Jaccard similarity which is for for two
communities a and B users commenting
number of users commenting on a and B
divided by number of users commenting on
a or B and the second the overlap
coefficient
is number of users commenting on a and B
divided by the minimum size of a and B
they say that the overlap coefficient is
more useful to compare communities of
different sizes so we'll look at that
the top graphs are always always two
chord difference and D or Jaccard
similarity in the bottom one are overlap
coefficient first graph though our
number of commenting users per year and
you already see that even though the
control group has much more views and
probably much more videos much larger
the comments don't they so the again the
the users of the all light and the
intellectual dark web are much more
engaged also comments per user this is
the cumulative distribution function
most people that comment on the on
control group videos maybe comment once
and then but but the these other
communities take the comment more
self-similarity means year after years
are always compared to the year before
how many users are similar so how many
how well do these communities retain
users and you can already see here the
control group is actually very bad at
retaining users it does have this
overlap coefficient high but it has the
jacquard same self-similarity low which
basically if you think of the formula of
the Jaccard similarity means that the
this number is small and this number is
high which means that a and b are very
disjoint which means that the last
year's users aren't this year's users
basically so they they constantly have
to appeal to new users because they're
losing old users because well i guess
they're boring and whereas the alt light
and intellectual dark web are much more
much that are at retaining users
interestingly the alt-right not as good
as retaining users as the other two this
could also be an effect of size like if
your community is smaller the users
might wander away more quickly but I
think this already speaks against the
radicalization pipeline if the if the
all right if YouTube was radicalizing
people towards alt right we I think we
would see a the alt right being on top
of user retention then here they have
intersections between communities so
green here is alt light and IDW while
the blue is all right and out light and
the other below result right and I do is
basically the green is ultra light and
IDW and the Blues are the other two and
we see that the overlap in terms of
overlap coefficient is similar the
overlap in terms of card similarity the
alt light and the IDW are very much more
sharing users which in the picture I
painted make sense if you think my model
is valid my model explains this very
well in that these two communities are
quite close together
therefore share a similar user base the
all right smaller and a bit further
apart therefore not as similar though
more similar than the control group
which is the last graph the last graph
is sorry the last graph is how similar
are these communities to the control
group
and here we see the IDW and the alt
light kind of similar um they all tried
not as similar though in the overlap
coefficient they're about the same so
the the paper here claims oh look at
look at the the similarity this is
definitely a radical isn't so they don't
claim yet this is a radicalization
pipeline but they they claim that
there's a higher similarity if you
actually look at the numbers it's not
it's not so I mean here your arm around
50% similarity and here at the end
you're also around the 50 percent
similarity with the control group so
this is within these groups and this is
here with the control group also here
your if I look at the kind of mean here
you're at whatever 20 18 percent and
here you're also you may be a bit lower
but you're also going towards this what
it looks to me like rather than there
being a radically a radicalization
partly if you look at the shape of this
and kind of where it starts in 2013 2014
it starts to go up here and you look at
the shape of this it's simply the same
shape delayed and I mean there's no
reason why this graph wouldn't go up
here wouldn't go up here in the future
and reach the exact same numbers as here
it seems that the graph is simply
shifted which makes total sense if you
think these communities are I'm going to
draw the same picture here alright IDW
light and over here control if you think
they're there they're like that if you
think simply think well YouTube is
growing users are growing users are
starting somewhere here and then
spreading out pretty much randomly like
they're spreading out spreading out
spreading out users start here spreading
out users start here spreading out here
spreading out everywhere users just kind
of there's a diffusion process going on
not in a particular direction like they
claim if there is just a diffusion
process going on what would you expect
you would expect users that started here
to reach the IDW and alright much sooner
then they reach the control group but
ultimately as the diffusion continues
all users will have commented on most
videos if you run YouTube infinitely and
these numbers would go that's why the
numbers go up right if you just let it
go the diffusion process will go along
and it simply takes a longer time to go
from here all the way over here then it
goes then between these communities so
to me we're looking at a simple
diffusion process here that is shifted
in time and that explains very much the
discrepancy in number but also the shape
of the curve that is exactly the same
but shifted their model does not explain
the shape of the curve they simply say
well here it's 75% and here it's only
50% that means that these communities
are kind of shipping users towards each
other
so I think the explanation is easier
then so they claim this does not alone
kind of show that there is a pipeline
what they now do however will show that
basically so they claim this is the
experiment that really shows that there
is it is pipeline so what they do is
they define what they call an infection
now so what they say is okay we are
for example this this row here we're
taking users that are alt light users at
the beginning in this time so basically
they only comment on the only comment on
all light videos during this time right
so discard all users that comment on
anything else just retain the ones that
only comment on all light videos during
this time then we're going to follow
them over time and
how many of them have at least one
comment in an alt right video so this is
only directed from the community over
here towards the all right and then they
call a user infected specifically if
they comment on one or two right videos
they're likely infected if they comment
on three to five they're mildly infected
and if they comment on or they're
severely infected so as you can see
users starting from the alt light or
from the IDW or from both they will
become in some will become infected over
time namely and I postulate we simply
look at the since the tendencies between
the groups are similar
we'll simply look at the light
infections here so they say okay after
you know in 2018 about eight to ten
percent of the users become infected in
these groups you see here here about the
same trajectories whereas so whereas in
the control group it's less here though
honestly I don't think it's that much
less right i I think that again I I
think there is a normal diffusion
process here they do this similarly with
the with the other ones and to me like
to them this makes total sense like oh
yeah users that start in these
communities they migrate they get
infected by the alright they go towards
your right because you can find it so
easily and to me this simply looks like
a normal diffusion process here's what
you need if you want and by the way the
control group isn't that much different
here's what you need if you want to show
that there is a pipeline in this
direction you need this exact same graph
in the other direction and you
to show that people that started in the
alt-right do not go back in the same
fashion towards the alt light or the iew
and they do especially not go to the
control group you need to show this
basically between each pair of these and
you need to show that the direction of
infection is only in a single direction
namely towards radicalization otherwise
you're just looking at a normal
diffusion process between differently
distance and differently sized groups so
they've go on to analyze they say well
how much basically how much of the
alt-right audience makes is made up by
people that have been radicalized that
have been infected so that this
infection is kind of their proxy for
what they call a radicalization and if
you become infected then basically
you're not a part of the alt-right or
something even though you might have
continued man might have commented
something negative actually the you
might engage with their ideas and call
them their crap but in any case you're
now infected and they ask themselves how
much of the alt-right audience has or of
these infected so basically how much of
the alt-right audience have our people
that in the past have been not alt
riders have been exclusively commenting
on all light or IDW videos and they find
that for example for alt light 23% of
the alt-right audience or former alt
lighters and have our former altar
lighters that have now made one comment
on an all-right video so that their
claim is well there is a sizable portion
of the alt-right that at the beginning
wasn't alright that basically became
infected and
therefore that that kind of shows this
radicalization pipeline that all tried
audience is mainly consistent of people
that have not been alright previously
but have become so and to me again this
is simply I function of the size of
these communities right if if you think
of this again and you start randomly
somewhere on YouTube let's let's make
this assumption people start randomly
somewhere on YouTube what's the
probability that you're going to start
in the all right very small right so
what's the the kind of natural let's say
the natural size of alt right before
users go on migrate is very tiny right
so not many users are going to be what
you would consult originally alt writers
whatever their their first comment
basically what this thing measures is
where is your first comment and are any
of your subsequent comments all right if
your first comment is not in the all
right then you become a potential
candidate for infection and if any
comment is on the alright then you're
infected so what's the probability that
your first comment is not alright well
you're gonna land somewhere on YouTube
YouTube is huge the outright is very
small thus that probability is extremely
small and then you let you simply let
people defuse let them defuse let them
defuse some will end up in the all right
and since the outright is so small to
begin with actually most people that
will comment at some point I'm an all
right video will will have their first
comment from somewhere outside the the
outright videos simply simply a numbers
game right simply the all right is so
small that this is virtually guaranteed
so what they find here is again simply
an evidence of a regular diffusion
process between these differently sized
groups
and the claims they make from this are
just over the top again that their
comparison to the control group if you
if you look at the numbers they're
actually not that different from this
from the IDW numbers they're they're
different than the alt light here
substantially different but again it
simply a function of distance in my
opinion in these in these clusters
lastly they look at the YouTube
recommender system and they say okay if
we look at these videos and the channels
and we look at on these videos what
other videos are recommended and what
other channels are recommended so if you
have like a video on YouTube you have
the video here and here you have like
recommended videos similarly when you
have a channel right you have a channel
this is a person yeah I'm this person
the person can have first of all they
can have featured channels where they
say look these are channels that I find
cool I go check them out and then they
also have recommended channels that are
kind of given by YouTube as
recommendations so here YouTube controls
basically everything here the Creator
controls part and the YouTube controls
dollar part so they look - but first of
all the channels channels recommend
recommendations so these are both
sections here and they look at if you
start on a alt light video how likely if
you do a random walk or you to end up in
the alt-right or in the interactive web
or control group after one step two
steps three steps four steps so that the
the big line is the random Walker and
actually the dashed line is the distance
if you were to target Lee go into the
direction of such a video like what's
the minimum number of clicks you need
and you can see here the the if you
started out light after one or two steps
the random walker is kind of a two
percent chance to end up at an all right
video and about a 25 percent chance here
of ending up in a intellectual dark web
video and about a 50 percent chance of
ending up again at an old light video
the scales here really different so it's
very difficult to judge how it compares
to the control group which is playing at
zero here but to me again this is a
reflection of the size of these
communities and I I think it's a bit you
know weird to to then claim oh these are
reachable basically so two percent
chance of landing on an all right video
um I'm not sure but again if you compare
if you start from the control group
there's almost no chance you'll end up
in a alt right video so I guess the the
comparison is is okay if you compare to
control group if you start look at
videos however again if you start at alt
light after one step you are
approximately 25 percent likely to be in
an IDW video you're a bit over 50
percent likely to stay in an alt light
video however compare this to channels
you're almost super unlikely to end at a
control channel if you start at an old
light channel but in video
recommendations you're actually also
about 25 percent chance of ending in a
control group video where as look at the
scale here you're only about point zero
three percent likely to end up in an alt
right video
and also here so here even look at this
if you start an IDW video the chance
that you're going to end up in a control
against super high much higher than an
alt light video whereas with the channel
recommendations this was completely
turned around so we see the alt-right
completely loses when it comes to video
recommendations and mainly the control
group gains compared to the channel
recommendations I think here's what I
think I think this is due to this
section here this section here where the
creators have power and also this
section here YouTube recommending I
think they're putting a lot of work into
the video recommendations I think
they're putting not that much work into
these recommendations and by work I mean
actually manually intervening and
deciding what's kind of good videos and
bad videos and the the control group
they're probably there's probably big
advertisement money in that so they
might be pushed up a bit in the video
recommendation since most people are
going by video recommendations I've
actually never used the channel
recommendations feature and the channel
recommendations first of all the creator
has power over part of it
and then also YouTube may not put as
much work into these related channels so
both have in the effect that I would say
the that the data here first of all it
doesn't doesn't convince me of a
radicalization pipeline it simply
convinces me that some communities are a
larger or smaller and closer together
but second of all that this down here if
you forget about alt right for a moment
yeah they're irrelevant this down here
actually compared to up here shows maybe
a bit of evidence of an algorithmic
promotion of these mainstream media
channels compared to how the communities
are actually clustering which I think
this this up here might be a much more
accurate picture so you know that it's
just kind of a funky thing in the data
yeah that's alright this irrelevant to
this part because they're they're just
too small so this is this is kind of my
take on this they didn't give
recommendations and is this a pipeline
and so on and I don't think so
you've now heard my idea and you've
heard their idea decide for yourself but
I think it's a good example of how if
you are convinced of an underlying
mechanism you're going to collect
evidence in support of that mechanism
and if you catch yourself doing that
really really think isn't there an
easier explanation for this
alright that was it for me have fun